communication Outreach conversation
engagement talking to a camera is a very
different skill than giving a lecture to
a bunch of undergraduates they're both
amazing and they both take a lot of work
to be good welcome everybody to an
exciting episode my favorite type of
episode a celebration episode an episode
celebrating 200,000 subscribers on this
YouTube
channel so we're going to have a little
bit of a party going through some
question that I got from Twitter from
YouTube from Instagram from threads from
Mastadon no I don't I'm not on Mastadon
remember everybody was saying they're
gonna abandon Twitter X whatever it's
called and go to Mastadon or blue sky
and I still see people saying they're
about to do that so uh I want to just
thank you guys so much for being a part
of this wild ride and GNA answer a bunch
of questions and hopefully uh you guys
will be uh be thrilled and stick around
and share the Channel with even more
people and there are people saying you
know some wonderful things in the
comments and I'm just so Overjoyed by
getting to do this my you know side
hustle I suppose you can call it it's
not my not my main hustle my main job is
teaching some of the most brilliant
students in the world at UC San
Diego where I have the honor of being
the chancers distinguished professor of
physics for the last four or five years
got a couple more years left on that
term and uh this year is really exciting
because we're starting observations with
the Simon observatory in just a few
months uh it's going to be a real
revolutionary instrument and I'm proud
to be one of the co-leaders of that
project and the initiator of it uh back
in 2015 it's hard to believe we in the
ninth year of it uh since it was just a
twinkle in the eye of Jim Simons and and
the foundation will hear more about that
this year it's going to be a great
celebration I'm also in the process of
of writing my fourth book which will be
a second volume of uh this book over
here in the background here in the
studio and the into the impossible
Studio into the impossible think like a
Nobel Prize winner volume
two coming out later this year we're on
uh deadline for that look for that
you'll hear more about that featuring
nine new never before written about
interviews that I've done with Nobel
Prize winners from various disciplines
including Peace Prize and economics
prize and of course a ton of physicists
including some who have never really
done podcasts or interviews like this
before and we distill their wisdom and
knowledge into actionable information
that no matter if you're a car salesman
in Oklahoma or you're an astrophysicist
in Nebraska anywhere in between those
two very distant locals you will benefit
from that knowledge and wisdom that I've
been the beneficiary of and you guys get
to be the beneficiary of as well last
thing remember to go to my mailing list
Brian king.com you'll get a chunk of
meteorite if you're one of the lucky
winners I choose each month we've got
10,000 plus people on the mailing list I
just can't believe it you I really just
started the podcast in Earnest four
years ago in the spring of 2020 during
the height of covid and I've been able
to uh really grow it and you know really
exceed my wildest dreams we hit 100,000
subscribers earlier this year uh sorry
in 2023 and we blown past that doubled
that and I don't see a reason why we
can't keep on growing all the way you
know maybe to the million Mark we'll see
because it all depends on how generous
you guys are by sharing it I don't
charge anything for it in fact I give a
lot of stuff away and I want to keep
doing that because it's a really a true
joy to be able to do that so got about
an hour on this uh special Q&A episode
and let's uh rip right into it okay so
there's a lot of you guys giving me
comments and congratulations I've seen
your channel grow says TCL 5853 and it's
more than welld deserved thank you so
much kudos to me and my team I do have a
great team shout out to Ryan and the
Legacy podcast me uh podcasting team uh
all around the world they do such a
great job turning the videos into
masterpieces and audio episodes and we
try to do a little bit different for
each you know format the video versus
the audio and uh so you can find that at
brian.com podcast
uh it's on Spotify obviously iTunes and
Google is going doing away with their
podcast software but you'll be able to
find it on YouTube
podcast um let's see uh Mera
madur 8260 says Dr best wishes hopefully
two million soon I don't know about soon
it's taken four years to get to 200,000
so 10 Xing that um you know soon uh but
it can happen and hopefully you guys can
be a part of it and say you knew me when
uh so it's been such a such a great uh
and lovely ride and so many of you just
congratulating Chad and Ronda uh maybe
it's two people maybe it's one person
says very best wishes to you and the
family thank you so much got the into
the impossible family and my research
team here at UC San Diego and Chile on
the Simon's Observatory and of course in
the podcasting sphere it says Hey foot
on the gas bro don't be a punk b word
and don't sell out all right well no
worries there I'm not going to sell out
uh I don't know who would be buying me
but um but this is uh this is kind of a
passion project so I love doing it and I
love when you guys give me these uh give
me the opportunity to speak to a camera
something that didn't really exist for
me and as a as a possibility for the
career uh you know kind of break for my
day-to-day job uh which I get to do and
talk to these phenomenal people I've
talked to 18 Nobel Prize winners couple
of poiter Prize winners some
billionaires astronauts writers uh
researchers and uh it's just going to
keep growing it's just going to keep
getting bigger and
better all right Karen cooner 3307 asks
if someone wants to learn about physics
but it's been a while since he she had
anything to do with it what books or
people would you recommend to read
follow also congratulations here to many
more years of success thank you Karen
coer um so there's you know there's a
lot of available on YouTube I don't you
know currently uh position what I do in
terms of only learning lessons about
physics it's not organized like that I
do teach cool experiments and do some
solo episodes as does my friend Sabina
hossenfelder who's you know the best in
the business and as an educator and
active
researcher um and there's you know tons
and tons of of assets and things online
that you could find um so starting off
you know the basis of physics is math
and having curiosity and understanding
of it so if you really want to get
deeper into physics that's um where I
would start so stuff in math and and
doing stuff um you know I am not this
video but I'm sponsored by
brilliant.org you can visit my uh
brilliant.org list I um my uh link will
get you uh some discount subscri
subscription I'll put a link to that
here down below um and the comment
section and they have you know
tremendous resources for learning know
basic science math and I actually use it
just for fun to learn about computer
science and stuff I'm not a particular
expert in and you know there's only so
much time to develop expertise in my own
field of of cosmology let alone to
really go deep into these other fields
like biology or uh computer science so I
really like them brilliant is a is a
great opportunity of course you know
it's not free uh there are other courses
um I've recorded a course for Peterson
Academy which will be a four um you know
it's you'll have to pay to subscribe but
you'll get access to all their courses
and great Educators from John Veri and
Brett Weinstein and many other uh
luminaries Jordan Peterson himself and
Vincent harinam and uh maybe some some
past guests that you've seen on this
podcast as well so that'll be coming
later 2024 uh but that's significantly
more expensive than brilliant but look
for I'll have some codes and stuff that
you can get access to that resource and
then obviously
books they're great books uh depending
on what you w
to specialize in uh Sean Carrol has had
uh some success with his uh book series
called the biggest ideas in the universe
the second volume is coming out in May
and the first one was about um uh you
know kind of the mechanics and and
gravity and forces and so forth and he's
going through his list and of his
YouTube channel which he recorded you
know three or four years ago as well so
you don't have to buy the book you can
just go to his YouTube channel and he
goes and great detail and he's a great
educator so that's free on YouTube or
you can get his book uh or do both uh
you know I'm sure he would appreciate
the uh the book sales as
well okay next question life 42 I love
you Dr Brian keing all the way from
Florida mitzvah for life all right wow
shabbat shalom to you
uh Ken Barnes
7669 says best hair in science Brian
thanks I recently paid it off so I am
quite thrilled that I still have it I
don't D it I'm starting to get a little
gray over here over there that's okay
I'm 52 years old you know it comes with
a
territory uh so you know I always say
people complain about getting older I
said you know beats the alternative so
uh just a great season of life last year
you know know uh it was one of the best
years of my life not the best year of my
life of course you know tempered by the
tragedies in Israel um in October right
after I was there in in September for my
birthday my bar
mitzvah anniversary uh so that put a
damper on the
year uh but we'll get through it and uh
you know hopefully uh things will come
out better than before stronger more
solidified and I hope to get back to
Israel maybe even this year we'll see um
got a lot of cool trips and stuff
planned meetups with people ranging from
uh you know my friend Peter teal and and
others in the in the spring to uh trip
possibly to Japan I've been in about 10
years see my buddies my collaborators at
the Japanese space agency and in Tokyo
University of Tokyo and that'll just be
phenomenal okay next on coming up uh
Jared doc DPP PC one congratulations
watching you from Mexico thank you
gracias I say uh next up and sases and
and and and SAS you guys have very
difficult to pronounce screen names uh
well done and thank you for your
persistence in doing more than just a
podcast thanks I do do that um I really
want to connect as I say a million Minds
to have a stem education for free and
being being able to get a uh get access
to the world's greatest Minds you know
where you guys get to ask some questions
I always post opportunities for you to
ask questions of my guests and nothing's
going to change in fact well you know
maybe even toying with the idea of doing
some live episodes with good friends and
past guests and want you guys to look
forward to that and maybe join me in
person that would be a real phenomenal
thing to do okay well anyway and he
asked uh so I will ask you for something
more because I get more than just the
podcast I remember when you went hiking
in nature and that seemed to bring you
great pleasure do you still do it or
have an exercise routine that makes you
feel good or goggin and cons
consequently sharper if so we'd like to
know yes I do try to exercise six days a
week uh on Sabbath I rest although I do
like to walk so yeah I go to the gym uh
try to do the gym five days a week and
Hike you know kind of on the weekends
and my kids and my wife I do love being
in nature I forget where that episode
was it might have been in Wyoming a
couple years ago um sought Refuge from
covid and we get to go back there on
occasion to a a little secluded spot
outside of Jackson Wyoming that's a real
incredible place and I don't get out as
much as I'd like to I would like to do
more and I do love to hike here in San
Diego County as well it's the only place
I've ever lived where you can go surfing
in the morning and you can go skiing in
the mountains cross country skiing not
really downhill skiing uh where places
like um Mount lagona or even where Mount
palar is in San Diego County and it
snows there in fact this weekend I'm
recording this in you know second half
of January it's quite cold and it's
supposed to snow above 6,000 feet and
it's supposed to be warm after that and
so one could Surf and then go hiking on
the same day now I don't know where you
live but uh it's pretty much the only
place I've ever known we could do that
now goggin uh is a special breed uh you
know for me the main thing is is is
Fitness uh I do like lifting weights I
do do a lot of um what's called my
routine is called strong lifts basically
six different or five different
exercises alternating you know three
days a week always involves
squatting um and then it alternates
bench press deadlift
lats uh shoulders and maybe one one or
two other things so I do like doing that
um I've always been into weightlifting
playing football doing stuff wrestling
Jiu-Jitsu craft Mah trying to get more
into flexibility as I get older because
you know strength is great and it makes
big difference according to people like
Peter AA or Andrew humman in terms of
longevity and quality of lifespan not
just you know how they call Health span
not just
lifespan but I'm trying to um you know
also always continually battle the
weight and you know try to always I'm
always on a diet I've never not been on
a diet since I was about 10 years old uh
and it's a struggle and it's something
you know it's my one addiction I've
never done a drug in my life and despite
you know Joe Rogan trying to get me to
try some mushroom cocktail or whatever
he had I didn't do it this is not a
mushroom cocktail anybody who's
wondering I've had a cold for about two
weeks not covid but some crud that I
probably picked up from a
kid and it's been pretty brutal I
haven't been able to really work out or
go you know in the
ocean um just taking a walk I try to
take a walk every day uh by myself with
my kids a couple miles get those steps
in and it is you know no doubt it does
blow you away things like depression and
amps you up and gets you you know in a
creative mindset and also for me I get
kind of debilitated being on telecons I
mean most of my job is being on telecons
for meetings in person it's not really
like building the telescope or analyzing
the data from it uh it's kind of
advising students on how to do it so
when I can be on a telecon a zoom call
and take that on my phone and go for a
walk you know around campus especially
we have a beautiful campus it's huge
there's a forest on campus that's my
secret kind of
getaway when you see me in nature
sometimes I'm over there and maybe I'll
do more Walkin talks like that it's been
kind of um a while since I did that so
yeah got to get out got to get nature
especially you know change your mood
change your mindset those are the kind
of only sorts of of routines that I can
imagine uh giving advice about uh where
I've been doing it you know essentially
my whole life I'd like to if I can lose
a little more weight I'd be back on the
running track and running through campus
rather than just you know walking
through campus but you know 52y old
knees you got to be careful um okay
thanks for that Chris
Zack Tian
3532 says congratulations my highlight
on this journey was you with Brian Green
also loved many of your other guests
like Frank wilch Carla relli and keing
in the Royal Institution you really made
it guy yeah that was a huge highlight of
my of my professional life I was able to
speak at the Royal Institution the
hallowed Halls of Michael Faraday of JJ
Thompson of uh Arthur Edington and keing
and so be yeah being there was a was a
true highlight one of the two they made
two videos one is a you know the hourong
uh discourse which I got to give I was
locked in a room before the actual
presentation my kids two of my kids
locked me in the room and I was uh
forced to wait there because in
Tradition has it that Michael Faraday
was once forced to give a talk as the
speaker abandoned his post right before
the lecture got nervous and and bugged
out and so Faraday initiated a a rule
for this type of talk called the
discourse that I in June of last year uh
that you got locked in the speaker got
locked in the room before speaking so
that he could not Escape or she could
not Escape so that was really fun so
that video uh did pretty well it's got
80 something thousand views in a couple
months but then they made a short and
the short is I mean it's not my best
word it's not my favorite video of all
time but uh I guess it was pretty cool
because it's got 6,2 200,000 views of me
with a a polar ier and showing what
polarizers do to light so it's pretty
pretty unbelievable anyway Chris says I
suggest you should retire now and enjoy
the rest of your
life all right well this has been fun
thank you Chris for the advice signing
off right I'm not gonna retire Chris but
uh he says or will there be even more
wink wink yes sir there will be tons and
tons more this year is going to be even
bigger than last year uh although last
year was pretty hard to top with
appearances with Jord Peterson Joe Rogan
and bench Piro and many other things I
got to do and have done to me uh and
that was just unbelievable ride and you
know I mean for me the the the thing is
to kind of just keep doing the great
content keep getting the great guests
and the way that you guys could help
again is really I mean it's it's kind of
surprising I mean I I do this with with
videos and channels I watch but I forget
to subscribe I don't like leave a
comment or I don't leave a thumbs up but
it does help I mean the algorithm
sometimes I'll have some video and just
be something you know I recorded six
months ago and I'll see it it'll just be
like going exponential and getting you
know 200,000 views in a weekend
something I did you know six months ago
so who knows but it has to do somehow
with how many people are sharing the
video so there's a button with an arrow
just click share even if you share it if
you just click uh share and then copy
the link and then paste it into another
browser so if you go from Safari or Edge
to Chrome or fir Fox that counts into
the algorithm and those are some of the
biggest things you guys can do again
totally free and that tells the
algorithm that this is a sharew worthy
video and YouTube likes that you know
more than anything because then they can
you know sell more ads I suppose um and
you know I don't control how many ads
get really shown or you know which ads
get shown helps to offset the cost of my
team is very expensive to do this and
I'm not support I get zero dollar I get
nothing from UCSD and people always ask
that and you know I can make a decent
amount but it costs a lot to support a
team of there's 14 people on the team
all over the world run by my friend Ryan
Helms and um in Austin
Texas but you know it's tremendous
amount of work to post to have show
notes to have uh content um Twitter post
Instagram Tik Tok we even have a Tik Tok
Channel Professor keing um and you know
it it takes a lot of time and money to
do that so um you know I try not to do
too many uh subscriptions like I said I
or promotions I do have brilliant I do
this thing called Ground news there's a
couple other places I'm trying not to do
like vpns and you know like do you
really care what I use as a
VPN King VPN no I I don't um I don't
have my own VPN yet okay uh next
question comes from swag at panda23 okay
that's reasonably easy to pronounce
congratulations Dr Kitt my question for
you would be to list out of five five of
the most promising fields in physics
that you think could change the world in
the upcoming decade or two well I'd be
lying if I didn't say cosmology is going
to change things especially because we
have these incredible observatories like
Simon's Observatory ver ruin Observatory
the Nancy Roman Space Telescope the
James web Space Telescope is just
getting started um there's nutrino
observatories like Ice Cube down at the
South Pole spoke to Francis Hollen the
pi and founder of it um year and a half
ago now um and uh just there's so much
happening in astrophysics because it is
the highest energy access that we have
in the cosmos it behooves us to really
study it and see if we can un unravel
the uh the properties of these
mysterious Concepts that we are
confronted with for everything black
holes um things in the black hole um
space I just talked to Andrea gz
yesterday she didn't want to come on the
podcast I have to say was disappointing
but you know I'm used to being rejected
by women but um but she she and I spoke
for a long time about her research and
how you know things are going to get
even more impressive with the 30 meter
telescope and the giant mellin telescope
coming online the next 10 years uh and
so you know black hole physics Event
Horizon physic telescope uh Imaging
other black holes understanding gravity
and extreme circumstances all these
extra solar planets that are being
imaged and um and mapped out and their
Spectra um so cosmology number one it's
got to be um that's possibly
self-interested but other
fields condense matter novel materials
you saw this past summer how interested
people were in claims of high
temperature superc conductivity room
temperature super conductivity that's
going to
revolutionize uh the world and it's
there's no obstacle to it we're getting
close to it um we still don't understand
the theory behind it exactly how it
works um that's a concern um so there's
a lot of progress that can be made in
theory and
experiment Material Science uh then of
course there's Fusion uh physics there's
um laser and Optical physics uh these
are branches of condensed matter physics
both theoretical and
experimental uh and then there are um
obviously ligo and gravitational physics
and strong gravitational fields more and
more understanding and cataloging of
rare events and seeing if we can see
simultaneous astrophysical uh you know
astronomical telescopes seeing events
when they are observed by ligo and Virgo
eventual spaceborn version of ligo is
planned and and hopefully uh on the not
too distant Horizon and then in terms of
um the uh the kind of inner world
biophysics you know kind of designer
materials and and applications of those
materials in the biological
realm um uh for you know kind
of understanding not only how to benefit
life as it is now but perhaps how life
originated in the beginning on Earth you
know I might say lastly I'm really
excited about the application of
artificial intelligence to physics how
we can uh perhaps generate or discover
new patterns new laws in physics I'm
kind of skeptical about that but that
doesn't mean I don't think it's a
promising field of physics so it's
computational physics it's machine
learning um I'm quite interested again
you know when you put two buzzword
together Quantum Computing and and
artificial intelligence uh we I don't
think we've seen really any super
promising applications yet from Quantum
Computing other than you know
understanding quantum physics better
which is incredible and truly important
um and maybe that will lead to some
breakthroughs and understanding the the
Lans that are involved in high
temperature superc conductivity but I
wonder if if there is is some special
Synergy that could occur when you marry
Quantum Computing and artificial
intelligence and um that coming online
could could really be truly
revolutionary so I think there's you
know it's the most exciting branch of of
science is I you know as far as I'm
concerned people are always interested
it covers everything from biology to
cosmology from the whole universe you
know astrophysics to zoology everything
is contained in physic and you know I
feel just particularly lucky to be on
The Cutting Edge at least in the
cosmology uh realm when it comes to the
Simon Observatory my colleagues are so
insanely smart and energetic and we
built an observatory from scratch I me
there's nothing up there it was Bare
rocks in 2019 July 2019 went up there
with Jim Simons Marilyn Simons David
spurgle and we broke ground on the uh on
the observatory and you know last year
we got you know the first photons coming
in the front end of one of the
telescopes so four years and that
required tremendous amount you know pave
Paving over the top of the mountain uh
building diesel fuel power generators
getting the diesel fuel up there and
getting tens of thousands of detectors
that we operate at 0.1 Kelvin to
actually start operating it's really
incredible engineering and then that's
just to get to the point where we get
data and you know get the time order
data into the uh disc drive and then
actually analyzing it terabyte of data
you know every every couple of weeks and
then processing those to actually get to
cosmological parameters and solve these
really Grand questions like the age of
the universe the composition the fate of
the universe the origin of the universe
physical processes like the renson
variants I'm super interested in and
you'll be hearing more about properties
of neutrinos dark matter it's just going
to be you know it's the experiment of a
lifetime so I I am just you know kind of
having to wrestle with what am I going
to do uh when this is over I mean it's
going to be over it's going to be
working for 10 years I mean we have 10
years of of uh observations planned with
it upgrades to it have already been uh
funded by the
NSF here in America by um the um United
Kingdom Japan um we have other people
interested from around the world as well
to upgrade and we're going to be
observing and eventually combining with
collabor called CNB stage 4 uh
eventually hopefully in the early 2030s
you know so I'm be in my 60s then and uh
you know just so many brilliant students
getting their degrees and professors and
posts and and just this flood Avalanche
of of just the most groundbreaking
research that I could ever hope I mean
so beyond my wildest dreams I'm so lucky
and uh and it's really a joy and I'm
going to take you guys on a ride with me
because you guys although the Project's
you know entirely for now is entirely
privately funded as I said the National
Science Foundation is funding the
upgrade the advanced Simon Observatory
doubling the number of detectors uh in
the next five years uh you know so
that's supported but I always feel this
moral obligation that you guys you know
allow me to do what I do and give me
this outlet and share this you know
Channel and uh and everything that I've
tried to bring to you and I want to give
back and answer your questions and give
you the information that you crave and
and that you're entitled to so you know
it's my small way to pay pay things back
okay next one Sam Cena
3942 awesome job Dr Kon you deserve it I
do have a question which I asked many
times was not fortunate enough to get
selected so I try again if the universe
had a beginning how can it be infinite
assuming it's flat W that's a really
good question so uh the the answer is
that if it had a beginning the um the
ability for information to Traverse the
universe or signs in the universe is
finite so for example we believe that
the universe is flat spatially flat um
but you can have something that's
spatially flat and it doesn't it's not
necessarily
infinite and uh because the universe had
this origination moment we believe if
the Big Bang is correct although we
should test that hypothesis it certainly
is um has a radius that we can ascribe
to it and in the case of the Big Bang
model that radius is roughly three times
the age of the universe times the speed
of light it's roughly 46 billion light
years in radius we don't know that it's
not infinite is the answer to your
question so it could be that our
universe is sort of this volume which is
spatially flat inside of a vast much
vaster perhaps infinite set of
four-dimensional points in you know what
you could call the entire Cosmos or you
could call that the Multiverse and there
could be other universes in different
locations which have different
properties that for example AR flat
that's completely in the realm of
possibility so um it is possible to have
a compact universe that is uh expanding
but if it had a beginning uh it doesn't
mean that what we say as our observable
universe is finite so it's not infinite
so the region the volume of our of our
universe is at least 46 billion years in
radius and then imagine you know a um a
spherical region of three-dimensional
space with that radius
so uh the diameter being as I said twice
that distance and the geometry could be
flat within that region assuming it has
what's called the critical density which
all indications seem to point to that
our universe has a critical density
meaning that it is spatially flat any
three Tri any triangles you make in the
universe no matter if those points are
stars planets galaxies or patches of the
cosmic micro background radiation all of
those triangles have an interior set of
Ang angles that sum to 180° and that's
the definition of flatness so yes we do
have a flat universe uh we don't know if
it's infinite it may be fin it this may
be all there is and there may be nothing
Beyond if you like that that region of
the universe but there's nothing that
prevents it from being infinite and just
inaccessible to us because the there
hasn't been enough time for light
traversing at the highest possible speed
to reach our telescopes and detectors
and indicate that the universe is in
fact beyond the visible uh radius that
we see so that's a great
question okay George dubben
6288 with your YouTube success would you
call yourself a pop science scientist do
you think that's necessarily a negative
term do you think it should be a
negative term I love the podcast cheers
from San Diego Thank you so much um I
don't know if I'm a pop science
scientist uh I do like communicating to
the public the populace I I do enjoy it
it's a skill I didn't know I had and
something I'm working on trying to
improve upon with you know coaching and
and studying of you know Great Master
communicators uh from the past like
great Carl San and current ones like you
know communicators like Joe Rogan and
Lex Friedman or they're they're great at
you know kind of popularizing stuff now
where where I'm different from people
there aren't very many actual scientists
Neil degrass Tyson is no longer doing
science he had a very very short brief
research career um and then and you know
pivoted and went into you know directing
the rose Planetarium and Hayden
Planetarium and um writing books and so
he wouldn't call himself a scientist
Brian Cox is a professor he's you know
my knowledge hasn't written you know you
know an extensive U of papers and he
does primarily seem to occupy himself
with popularization and and Outreach in
books and and speaking tours and stuff
like that um I don't think it's a NE
negative thing I I kind of see it
conversely it should be encouraged that
you know my my hobby horse is that more
scientists should be doing this because
we get paid by the public you know Brian
Cox Works in a you know lives in a
socialist no it's not socialist but he
lives in a in a you know a country is
you know completely supported by there's
no like private funding for experiments
or you know observations over there so
yeah he's a public servant I'm a public
Ser you know I teach at the public
university of the State of
California so do believe that everybody
should spend some time learning the
skills to communicate to the public not
with a goal of making it um their
primary career like Tyson or even their
side hustle like me but simply uh
developing the muscles and the skill set
needed to enthus the general public that
does support us so that they'll continue
to get a sense that they are getting a
return on their investment you know
during the 60s and 70s when people
landing on the moon you know it wasn't
clear that you know every day life was
getting better you're getting better
education but there was a source of
Pride for people going to the Moon uh
now it's Private Industry you know
SpaceX they're getting paid tons of
money and you know elon's the richest
guy in the world but um but that doesn't
mean that you know people are getting a
tangible benefit from it even though
they might have pride or interest in it
so for me it's like you should really do
as much as we can to engage the public
and by doing that that does kind of
enhance my appreciation for what I do
and it really does inculcate the sense
of
gratitude that I'm going to be um you
know continuing to support you uh in
this Mission which you guys Provide
support to me by um you know asking
these great questions and and you know
and just showing the enthusiasm and
sharing and and everything that you guys
get to do so for me it's it's not a
negative term it shouldn't be a negative
term even if that's all you do like
Tyson I don't think it's bad uh you know
what he does I'm not gonna give him
grief I don't agree with all of his
positions and you know I've been on his
show he's been on my show um but you
know I feel pride in that there aren't
many like real honest to goodness
professors that are also doing podcasts
you know Sean Carol recently became a
professor you know for the second time
uh now he's at uh John's
Hopkins his mindscape podcast is you
know is pure communication and and
popularization he has great guests and
and uh great conversation so he does it
he's a real Professor Andrew huberman's
a real Professor you know he's he's a
real scientist he's he's in that by
definition I mean doing research
publishing papers advising students um
you know interacting with faculty
meetings uh serving on committees you
know I just came from a we had a
committee to give honors and awards to
other professors students and post talks
or um we have a graduate admissions
committee meeting this week U these are
all things you know service jobs that
real professors do that you know someone
like Neil degrass tyon is not going to
do that there's nothing for him to do
but you know if he can bring in you know
million people per year into the Hayden
planetarium that's phenomenal so um and
I don't begrudge people that don't do it
I just think they're missing out and you
have to ask you know when people are not
doing stuff uh is it because it's too
hard like normally I've had this debate
with Sabina and you know she said oh no
scientists should just do science and if
you want to communicate you can
communicate uh because it's not their
skill set it's not easy for them well
this isn't easy for me I had to learn
I've been studying this for the last few
years I'm not that great at it but um
but I'm better than somebody who's even
better than me who never does it so you
know for me I'm in the arena I'm trying
to do it I'm not perfect I'm trying to
improve super fun and um I enjoy it and
so I think people putting that together
it's like if you said well uh I I you
know I don't do Quantum field Theory
because it's too too hard well what if
you're you know what if that's your that
is your job I mean just cuz something's
hard and it's not in your natural skill
set you shouldn't do it like I told you
I exercise but I don't like exercising
half the time uh you know some sports I
like I like to go skiing I like to go
surfing uh but other than that and like
just running around a track I mean I
don't like that I know there are
psychopaths that do like that Ryan
holiday or something like that but uh I
don't like it um so you know so not
doing something because
hard that seems to me might be a
tremendous cop out now they push back
and say I shouldn't say it's a moral
obligation it's kind of tongue and cheek
I'm not gonna damn you to Eternal
damnation if you don't do it but it may
benefit you communication Outreach
conversation engagement talking to a
camera is a very different skill than
giving a lecture to a bunch of
undergraduates they're both amazing and
they both take a lot of work to be
good okay Dr Teddy Ving says well met or
chap thank you Governor okay this guy
can't pronounce his name what the I'm
like GNA f f word I'll say what the f
word honestly I haven't learned anything
from you you've ever said on any podcast
but I do feel you have some important
role to play in all this unfolding I
hope you make the right choices defined
by yourself and that deep truth of
yourself that I hope you learn to
commune with we will see the fundamental
shift of human authority back from those
exercising distant Authority because the
future may fall to you then you know
many of the Gods most critical servants
were humble the Frailty of the servant
exalts the name by which they
conquer wow um I wish I could pronounce
your name uh legally on the line um and
he goes on to ramble about some other
stuff about Mortal beings and keep
yourself also humble so it may be useful
as a servant um humility is a constant
theme I do think about it I know Moses
Who was the humblest man who ever lived
which he wrote himself in the Torah uh
supposedly so uh you know we can always
be more humble but in science you have
to have a little bit of swagger as well
you can't only be humble you can't only
think of yourself as less than or
unworthy um you must also have a little
bit of swagger in order to accomplish
great things you have to dare greatly
you have to have a little bit of hutzpah
and those are uh those are necessary
ingredients humility mixed with a little
bit of ner nerve are the two kind of
secret ingredients to get just the right
proportions uh it's always a challenge
but it's one I'm going to continue
trying to meet okay the memes of
Destruction longtime friend
congratulations thank you my friend Pete
from the woods says must be doing
something right keep it up thank you so
much okay uh Chris Tinley 5213 says can
you have Eric Weinstein back on to talk
more about his theing I think it's
really interesting it's hard for me to
understand I like that law he's
brilliant and maybe he could try
explaining it all so geometric symmetry
I think uh please excuse my spelling I'm
a thinker not a writer love what you do
i' also see the Newton doll please
Newton doll is um he's on sabatical
right now I don't know where he is so
Eric and I talk a lot I talked to him
recently after the New Year um you know
he's been in an interesting phase of his
life kind of withdrawn a lot from know
Public public scene uh you have noticed
he's has not really been available on uh
Twitter he's kind of withdrawn from that
um he's told me he's experienced you
know just
tremendous hostility pain frustration um
not personally but just kind of the
world collapsing and people uh just just
showing their worst sides and and I I
agree I've seen some horrible things
both in the online space but also even
on person on campus you know having
people you know celebrate the mark ERS
of Hamas on um on October 8th on this
very campus um and really just just
completely upending my view of what a
university was and I think Eric also has
been traumatized in some sense by all
the events we saw you know his three
academic institutions at Harvard MIT and
Penn uh and the presidents and their
awful abor behavior in front of Congress
and I've been talking with a congressman
is a friend of mine Kevin
Kylie uh who I've known for a while now
big supporter great uh brilliant young
guy who's got a huge incredibly
brilliant future ahead of him uh in
Congress and maybe even Beyond and you
know Kevin and I have been talking about
ways that we can improve higher
education and one of those ways is
really to democratize and make it
cheaper make more students get accepted
have school go you know full 12 months a
year why do I need three months off
every summer I I love what I'm doing I
do it it for
free um and uh we could have you know
have 30 you know 25 30% more students on
campus if we just did it all year round
and imagine the different Community we
turn away whole graduating classes every
year and we already have a huge campus
but U this is just one campus of the
Thousand top universities in the world
in America why why is it that all of
them shut down like my kids Elementary
School in the summer it doesn't make any
sense so Eric been you know uh
justifiably disillusion we have had
plans to get together I want to he wants
to do the next podcast in person and so
do I so it's just coordinating our
schedules we're going to do it we're get
it done soon uh I'll get them to talk
more about geometric Unity he's had some
uh new ideas about it new thoughts about
it um and uh some excitement and maybe
connecting it cosmologically I'm always
trying to figure out you ways to make
predictions that are observable and the
cosmological uh F field that I have
access to rather than you know purely um
high energy particle physics or string
theory predictions that I have no
special inclination or ability to test
uh so it'll happen and hopefully it'll
be in person and I'm trying to do more
inperson interviews I did one with Craig
Venter uh in December that was just one
of my favorite episodes didn't get that
many views I'm kind of surprised because
he said some stuff on that podcast very
critical of you know Anthony fou and
Francis Collins who is his rival on the
Human Genome Project that he just
utterly
obliterated um back in uh the early
2000s um he's just a bold outspoken
genius a real Maverick has a sailboat
goes around the world is
multi-millionaires founded multiple
companies and he's just so he's just so
funny and and bold and such a great
scientist I mean I just learned so much
from him and uh yeah I just want you
guys to show love you know uh always
leave a comment on the videos but yeah
share them because the more people I see
you know kind of that's a once in
a-lifetime interview you know I don't
know how many podcasts he's ever done I
think it was his first uh and he's just
you know a unique individual and and
same with Stephen Wolfram I got him to I
stumped him one of my questions kind of
he was said he had to go and think about
it and this is this is a guy who said he
finally understands quantum mechanics I
think Richard feeman his former tutor
and teacher would be uh be quite uh
quite impressed and maybe shocked to
hear him say that so yeah look for
interview with Eric coming soon don't
know when but it'll happen Okay do you
hold any opinions HR Brown 29 asked our
understandings now that you didn't
before you started YouTube and if so
what are your thoughts on how working
exposure in different spaces influences
people's growths and worldview that's a
great question as I said this is a very
different track uh than being a
professor so and being a professor isn't
there's nothing just one skill Professor
uh and similar there's not just one
skill of being a podcaster um and doing
interviews and or making solo videos I
make a lot of solo videos I've had um
you know slowed those down just because
I've gotten so many opportunities to
talk to these amazing guests you know
Brian Green Steven wlfr uh Sam Harris
coming soon MGA
dot um Veri all these incredible people
and so I haven't had time just to go
into the studio and record but I will
I'll do some more solo videos I really
enjoy those those are fun
and love to give you sneak peeks into
research and what it's like to be an
experimental physicist unlike you know
Brian green or or uh you know Brian Cox
or NE the grass Tyson whatever I do
experiments and that's a very different
skill set so yeah I've learned a lot
from um talking to people and and kind
of being a better trying to improve as
an interviewer I I I had a tendency for
the first three years i' I've tried to
improve it you know Meandering questions
and trying to be too focused on what my
guests thought of me and perhaps I was
trying to impress them or you know um
and it came off as me dropping names but
in reality when you meet somebody on a
podcast something I didn't appreciate
maybe you don't appreciate a lot of
these people like you know when I talk
to Sam Harris I've never met him in
person and he doesn't know anything
about me and so there's a huge asymmetry
of information I don't expect them to do
like read my three book you know no he's
guest on my podcast and many these
people have been you know done many many
podcasts and so when I would say well I
talk to um you know Donald Hoffman uh
when I'm having a conversation with
Robert spolski about Free Will and
Consciousness or Sam Harris you know I'm
not doing it to drop names of how
important I am I mean they wouldn't have
agreed to come on the show if they
didn't think I had some value or
importance so that yeah they wouldn't
have come on so I'm not trying to
necessarily impress them but just to say
here are the bonafides that I have I'm
not coming to this like a newbie I've
done my research I've talked to other
people people I'm hoping that you Sam
seosi whoever will give me some insight
into an effect or Theory or an idea that
I didn't understand from the previous
guest you know I've I've continually
said that I have great difficulty
talking with people you know talk about
Consciousness because it's so squishy IL
defined and they seem to not even be
able to Define you know these terms like
Consciousness and so forth I mean I had
the foremost you know progenitor of the
idea of Consciousness the hard problem
you know David charers and I didn't come
away feeling like wow now I finally get
it so I had a tendency to uh to really
you know kind of um make Meander and ask
you know rambling questions in a sense
uh always in you know trying to have it
in good faith and I'm trying to do more
push back and you'll see when the
interview with sapolsky comes out if
it's not out already yeah I push back on
him I I don't agree in his sense that
there is no free will I approached it
from an experiment the physics
perspective rather than just you know
like I feel like a lot of the interviews
with him are people that already bought
you know what he's selling and and I
didn't and so I was respectful that's
the key you can't I can't talk to
somebody even if I vehemently in some
cases dislike them n Chomsky is not one
of my you know I wouldn't want him to
watch my you know my kid um I have a lot
of respect for him scientifically and a
lot of um disrespect and and concern for
him as a as a political thinker as a you
know as a sort of a pundit and I think
he's had some really abor views
especially around covid and and even
around in politics and and certainly
around Israel so um now if I went off on
him you know that's gonna be the end of
my you know podcasting career and I I
don't think that's a a good way to go
about that now I'm not like Lex fredman
I'm not gonna just like everything is
love and just you know only gonna ask
softball questions and I'm not saying
Lex only asks softball questions but um
he's
his prime directive is to increase love
in the universe that's his mission my
primary directive is to spread Wonder uh
knowledge and curiosity to the world so
it's a little bit different we might
overlap and you know I've learned a lot
from Lex and and being a guest on his
show but it's very different it's a
different vibe that that he's trying to
construct and I don't really know too
many people that do that are pushing
back um and I think that it's kind of a
form of what they call benign bigotry of
low expect like if I push back on Sam
Harris is he gonna not like me and so
what if he doesn't like me you know is
he going to be my my best friend no
that's not really my goal my goal is to
ask questions that you guys want me to
ask and if I'm pulling punches you know
because I'm talking to you know Sam
Harris you know am I gonna talk to him
about Hunter B's laptop I mean that's
not like something where an experimental
astrophysicist has a specific area of
expertise so I think the worldview of of
talking to people treating them like
they're your friends um is dangerous but
it's uh it's an easy trap to fall into
similarly just doing what your audience
wants you to do like if if if I had my
way I did a survey you know last year
and you know asked what do you guys want
to hear about and I was afraid it would
be like oh aliens and get David grush on
and get this guy and talk you know
Smackdown Mick West and um and I even
got criticized by certain podcaster his
name I'm not going to mention because
he's kind of uh G off the deep end but
you know oh well you won't come on my
show and you just don't want to talk to
somebody who really knows the truth
about Al it's just truly Preposterous uh
there's no evidence that they have any
scientific bonafides and then he was
like lying about you know that he got me
my first thousand viewers even though I
met him in 2021 two years a year after I
started the podcast when I had 25,000
subscribers and now I've got twice as
many as he has so you know just like
there's just so much passion about like
UFOs and and I'm you know I haven't seen
any evidence for the existence of
extraterrestrial life let alone
extraterrestrial intelligence let alone
intelligence visiting the earth now that
may disappoint you because that's you
believe that and you believe there's
conspiracy cover it up and the
governments somehow miraculously been
able to obscure this Co you know
conspiracy for the last 80 years and yet
they can't you know keep the most basic
facts about uh you know uh other other
types of conspiracies uh hidden for more
than a couple of days and and you know
all the different scandals of every
single presidential Administration and
even conspiracies that didn't happen you
know Russia hoax and this thing or the
you know uh uh the Fast and the Furious
under Obama or you know whatever the
Biden and barisma let's say that did or
did you know they're so inapt on one
hand the government but they're so
they're the most prolific I mean they
put to shame you know the Chinese
Communist Party um you know in terms of
suppressing information our government
because they've been able to cover up
the biggest news story in the history of
the planet and for what purpose so
anyway you have to be careful as a
podcaster and I've learned that because
it's very tempting I've seen people my
friend you know Kurt jongle he's done
just so much content in the alien space
and you know and he's probably better
than anybody about it and you know
obviously Lex has done a lot of these
podcasts and I I've to and I'm just not
that interested in it until I see you
know significant evidence and then I'll
be probably one of the most interested
people on the Earth but I hasn't risen
to that level yet now I still talk to
people like AI lob and Gary Nolan and
and Eric you know is very interested in
this he's also become obviously
disillusioned and and claimed that you
know this is almost complete nonsense as
far as you can tell interdimensional
beings and and biologics from non-human
entities and and he's talked to he knows
grush personally they they talk on the
phone all the time and uh and he doesn't
believe a word of it so uh I don't think
that this is you know a direction that
would be fruitful for me to continue
going down to and investing in even
though I know I can get tons and tons of
views and subscribers and whatnot it's
just not worth it to me it's called
audience capture and I I I refuse to do
it because again I'm not doing this for
my living you know if I had to make a
living off you Kurt or Lex or you know
Joe or you know they make their living
off of it I get paid in a decent amount
for being a professor and I love doing
what I'm doing and that's my job and
this will always be my hobby and the
worst thing you could do for the love of
your hobby is to try to monetize it so
and the easiest way to monetize it would
be to just do whatever you guys want me
to do I'm not going to do it I'm going
to ask questions I think you guys want
me to ask questions I'm gonna get guests
that I think you guys want me to to
speak to but I'm not gonna Pander and
say um so this this has been a a
revelatory thing that HR Brown is asking
about and uh and I'm I appreciate the
question okay Miller
Joe uh 4582 says it's almost irritating
it's not 2 million considering the
import importance and topics you bring
to the table well you guys can keep keep
me growing you know just as I said do me
a favor right now just take your go to
the little arrow which is a share Arrow
somewhere down here and uh and click on
it and copy the link and then whatever
browser you're using you probably have
another browser on your phone or your
computer and just paste it into that
browser and that'll count as a share and
then like it on that you know account or
whatever and then send it to your to
your brother to your friend to your kid
the more people that subscribe I mean
only like 20% of you watching are even
subscribed and I I get it it's you know
I'm lazy too like I said I watch a you
know I I'm I I'm on a bunch of podcasts
and I just get lazy and I don't
subscribe to their Channel just do it
and the faster we can grow and you know
the faster it's a it's a truly positive
feedback loop so the more that you guys
can help in the process the better okay
daily D Steven 7855 says I'm interested
in hearing more discussions on the
energy front sustainability where are we
heading what's buyable for us electric
fuels versus fossil fuels battery
industry nuclear green energy great
question I plan on doing more of that
I've had on people like Steve coonan I
had on Tim Palmer who was you know
recipient of the Nobel Prize in 2006 and
I had on David fredberg from the all-in
podcast so yeah what can we do in terms
of new technology um a nuclear I'm a
huge proponent of nuclear energy we have
six nuclear reactors 10 miles from
campus uh you know in the San Diego Bay
and the different aircraft carriers
submarines and so forth that we have in
the port totally safe never had a
problem no reason we couldn't hook all
those up to you know the power grid San
Diego is pretty blessed with sunshine
and wind power and everything the desert
not Mojave desert's not far from here
I'd like to see every flower bloom
nuclear green energy wind solar uh
Battery Technology these are just
fascinating things power generation and
space um and then of course on the
efficiency Frontier here of reducing
losses uh super conducting
technology um and lowcost energy which
also involves cool things like literally
cool things like cryogenics and and
vacuum technology um this is a you know
wave of the future and if we're not
careful we'll you know we'll fall behind
we've already not had a new more than
one nuclear reactor built per year uh
longer than since nuclear power was
invented in other words we've only had
one come online the last couple years in
America where other countries are coming
online and then there are other
countries that are decommissioning like
Germany and Japan fascinating question I
do plan on doing that and look for um
new uh discussions on Fusion Energy
laser laser power or laser um ignition
facility and maybe some stuff on you
know in person we're actually building a
large
photovoltaic um array power generation
and battery for the Simons Observatory
this uh NSF grant that we got marked
Evelyn at upen uh my my partner and
crime uh he is the pi of the advancement
proposal and that's uh you to provide
you know megawatts of power capability
make us the first green observatory in
the world uh you know on the Earth's
surface of every single uh Space
Telescope is is green energy powered but
uh but no we're going to have actual
replacement for a large amount of the
diesel fuel that would otherwise be you
know Up and
Smoke okay Emily Hollands 53 says I
enjoy this channel appreciate your hard
thank you Emily we have a lot of women
that listen to the channel I love it um
more and more spread the love um I I
also get uh comments from my female
colleagues why don't you have more women
on I've had more women on as far as I
can tell than any podcaster including
Lex and Joe and um but uh but I can
always do more and I love doing it and
so yeah if you have suggestions for
great scientists send in my way we do
have some I've had interviews um with
some uh great women that are you in the
uh recording and editing process uh but
please send me more great scientists I
love to promote them especially when
they have books and things I can promote
and help them promote
themselves how do you think of the
expansion rate of the universe asked
will Francis in terms of raw speed I
often hear 70 kilometers per megap Parc
so it's 70 kilometers per second per
megap Parc and that's the so-called
Hubble constant so what the Hubble
constant says is that if you go out a
sufficient distance such that a Galaxy
that we observe a star Within which uh
that Galaxy is not being gravitationally
attracted to the to the Milky Way galaxy
as say the Andromeda galaxy is the
galaxies Beyond about a 100 megap parex
away from the Milky Way galaxy are
within what is called the Hubble flow
meaning that they are all expanding
there are no galaxies beyond that
distance that are being attracted say to
the Milky Way or the Virgo group or a
local super cluster Lena or whatever so
instead those galaxies are participating
in the expansion of the universe
uh which is uh which is of you know
pretty much the most important number in
all of cosmology is the Hubble constant
because the reciprocal of it is related
to the age of the universe and its value
is directly related to aspects of its
composition including the amount of dark
energy and dark matter so that means if
you looked at a Galaxy that's over 100
megap par xoa which is 100 times a
million times a Parc which is 3.24 Light
Years um uh you will see that Galaxy and
every other Galaxy at that exact
distance moving at a velocity of 70
kilometers per second per megap Parc
meaning that that Galaxy so it's 100
megap parcs away so it's going to be
moving at 7,000 kilometers per second
and the Hubble tension is the difference
between the uh value measured by the
cosic mro background which measures a
lower value like 68 kilometers per
second per me par and the uh optical
telescope measurements by Adam Reese and
other people Space Telescope Wendy
fredman that measur something like 72
and each one has a very small error bar
so 68 plus or minus a percent and 72
plus or minus percent so those two
values differ at the 9% level and each
one believes that they're right at the
1% level so that's the so-called Hubble
tension and experiments like the Simon
Observatory and the ver ruin Observatory
and other observatories that are coming
online will hopefully to answer that
Knight 3481 says let we're here because
Mitch okaku and Eric Weinstein are out
of control all right fair enough uh
Thomas SC Thomas corbette says I'm a
very nice man thank you Thomas red shift
quation say red shift is not a discount
so what is red shift why red shift
quantization is a topic rejected by vast
astrophysic community so red shift
quantization was a proposal in the 50s
and 60s that uh people like Halton ARP
who was a great astronomer
claimed that they saw that red shifts
were only coming in certain increments
so that there was not a continuous
Spectrum if you will of the red shift
now remember the red shift is the amount
of um of of uh shift of the wavelength
either to the long wavelength I.E the
red end of the electromagnetic spectrum
or if it's coming towards you into the
blue portion that'll be a blue shift and
one of the reasons is that there we only
see beyond this 100 megap Parc distance
where the Hubble flow is at to
begin we only see uh red shift we never
see a quantization where the there's a
decrement in the uh red shift such that
it's a blue shift so uh if there were if
this process were a valid process you
would expect to see equal amounts of red
shift and blue shift and we only tend to
see red shifted objects uh Beyond as I
say the gravitational influence radius
of the Milky Way galaxy or of our
clusters so it's really there is no real
evidence for quantization of red shift
there's no plausible model that would
explain it why it would be quantized
these aren't photons these are photons
from the galaxies but now the the claim
was that these galaxies were actually
their their actual red shift their
location in space was actually quantized
and that you shouldn't find objects at
certain regions that could have been
because of systematic errors or bias in
the survey and not uh our ability
to uh actually determine them was the
limitation rather than a true physical
phenomena where the red shifts were
coming in chunks a Delta red shift of
0.1 we actually see a pure Continuum we
don't see any evidence for quantization
of red shift okay last question that's a
good one Edward wayer says is there a
guest you really wanted to interview but
would not let you interview them yes
there many many people who won't let me
interview them uh ranging from Ed
Whitten um who declined to be
interviewed uh there are people who said
they would let me they would come on the
podcast like Scott Galloway who I
received an introduction to said he
would do it sent him five emails never
replied to me which I told him is very
low class thing to do for you know
somebody who especially uh being a
graduate alumni of the University of
California to not come on I'm the you
know host of The Biggest podcast the
oldest podcast in the University of
California you know Network although as
I said the university doesn't support me
at all but they do tolerate me I
appreciate that so for T Scott not as a
just as a Alum of Berkeley and UCLA to
not come on blow off this introduction
uh was kind of unfortunate especially
since I think there are a lot of people
that would benefit and enjoy hearing
from him but you got to reply and
there's no way to do it unless you reply
so Whitten is one um Nima akani hammed
um agreed to come on three years ago now
uh and he was really gungho he's very um
very uh gentlemanly said he would come
on um and uh in the last two years I
haven't heard anything from him so not
going to bug him I I'll I'll get around
I'll see him we'll we'll do it in person
maybe he'll host a a conference or
something and I'll I'll Ambush him there
uh Peter teal has agreed to come on I
just have to make it
happen um he's a very interesting person
to talk to no matter what you think of
him politically I'm not you know super
interested in politics per se as I've
talked about um uh I would I would like
to talk to um you know I had Joe Rogan
on uh sorry I didn't have I was on his
show um and I I I'd like to do something
with him um I'd like to do something
with Jordan Peterson I've been on their
podcast Lex Friedman and turn around uh
I think the the one you know that
that'll probably happen hopefully this
year's Andrew huberman um not from the
perspective of like well tell talk to me
about you know light exposure and cold
plunges you know he's talked about that
ad nauseum um and so what I think people
like when I talk to them is as a phys
physicists they love to nerd out there's
so many closet nerds science fiction
nerds astrophysics nerds everybody loves
as there's no one say oh you're an
astronomer okay can you please pass the
the the cream cheese uh people are
interested in it it's a fascinating
field I get to do it um you know on The
Cutting Edge what I do I'm blessed to
have a research group that's second to
none and to do you know Cutting Edge
Publications and top journals so uh I
love doing it and so what I'd love to do
is talk to these people about something
they've never talked about
uh when Andrew huberman has not talked
about you know kind of the effects of
the electromagnetic spectrum or
polarization of light or um or or how
you know dial and circadian rhythms are
are intimately related to the to the
fabric of our of our planet and and what
those have to do and and actually the
biological implications of the planetary
limitations of our of our home planet so
these are all incredible topics um he's
invited me on his podcast
but communicating with Andrew huberman
is like uh what I believe will be like
when we first hear from an alien
civilization that's you know kind of uh
more than 10 light years away from us
and that you know we text each other and
then like I hear from him and then the
next text I'll send them right back you
know I'm like an eager beaver right uh
except they come on the hman Lab podcast
and then like three months later get
another text you we're setting it up
I'll wait for my producer so um it'll
happen and when it does I'll let you
guys know and you guys will submit some
questions for Dr Andrew hberman or for
you know Joe Rogan or whoever and you
know tell me I got a great list of uh
suggestions and you could always send me
suggestions at brian.com I got about 50
different suggestions from you guys for
um either returning guest or new guest
and some of them are great and some of
them are you know actual guests coming
on the podcast so look for that uh I
just want to thank you guys I'll see you
at
250k and uh hopefully Beyond and you
know like I said I really want to grow
it so you guys can do your part it's
totally free subscribe send uh your
friends you know watch it on multiple
channels multiple browsers uh do what
you can and I just love it and I love
that you guys give me this opportunity
look for more Walkin talks look for some
q&as I just you know love doing it and I
have a blast doing it and being with you
guys thank you all from the bottom of my
heart 200k never thought I would be here
but now once you get there you get the
honic treadmill and now I'm like maybe
250 maybe two million as one of you guys
said so thank you all so much take care
stay tuned this is only the beginning
bye